Transcriber: Leslie Gauthier
Reviewer:
The wheel was invented a long time ago,
but we’re way behind.
Hi, my name is Jane Velkovski.
I’m 13 years old,
a student in a public school
and a passionate football fan.
In addition to that,
I’m a kid with a disability.
My condition is known as SMA:
spinal muscular atrophy,
where the muscles are getting weak
but the brain remains strong.
I love football.
I'm a passionate football fan,
and my passion
has brought me so much joy
and so many great experiences --
so far, more than I could
have ever imagined.
For example, I was offered to join
a brilliant campaign by UEFA,
that is the Union of European
Football Associations,
to raise awareness about equality
and accesss issues.
It meant,
among other things,
I got the honor of public recognition,
public space
and I got an opportunity
to meet several
famous players who are my heroes.
I have also had the opportunity
to speak at the General Assembly
of the United Nations in New York
as part of the World Children’s Day
celebration in 2019.
These are just a few
of the amazing moments
I’ve been able to do.
But the thing is,
it’s not just a coincidence
or simple luck that this happened to me.
I was able to do all of this
not because it was easy
or simple to perform,
but because some important things
were given to me,
like the support of my family, of course,
inclusive education
and the environment I was raised in --
but also very much
because of my wheelchair.
It literally has made
all of this possible.
I’m independent with my chair.
I’m free to go wherever I want to.
I’m able to do things
I couldn’t otherwise.
My motorized wheelchair gives me three
incredibly important things:
freedom,
independence
and ability.
Some people ask,
“isn’t it just a wheelchair?”
It seems like a small thing,
no big deal.
But it’s not.
It’s a big deal to me.
It's what made all of this possible.
But the question is:
Do you think every kid like me
has a wheelchair?
No.
I did a little research
and I found out that today,
over one billion people require
assistive technology
to achieve their full potential,
but 90 percent do not have the access
to the assistive technology
that they need.
That means only one in 10 people
with disabilities,
who are in need of assistive technology,
have them.
I’m that one in 10;
I’m the lucky one.
But still in my country,
I’m not eligible to get a power chair
until I’m in school,
which means around six years old.
So from two to six years old,
how am I supposed to move
myself around independently?
I’m supposed to be pushed
by another person
when I want to get out of bed
or go outside my home
before the age of six?
Do you think this is OK?
No, not at all.
So let me tell you how I got my chair.
I was around two
when I started to wheel around.
Every day, out with my neighbors,
but first using my manual wheelchair
pushed by my mom --
which, to be honest, kind of makes it hard
to be just a kid hanging out
with his friends
when your mom was always right there.
My parents had been looking for ways
to get me a power wheelchair
a long time before school,
but it took them years to finally have it.
When I was five years old,
a year before I started primary school,
I got this power chair.
And it was not from the government
or health insurance
or even because my parents
could afford it,
but because it was a donation
from another family overseas,
from a child with SMA who had outgrown
the chair in the United States.
It was a gift in every sense.
Their donation gave me
the freedom I needed so, so much.
Now my mom says I have a better social
life than all her friends and herself.
When I was a very small kid,
my parents, like others,
were usually speaking on my behalf
to the people in our surroundings.
Even to the kid down there,
answering questions about my chair,
my legs,
my condition --
all of that.
They were saying,
“Oh yeah, sure, he can play.
His legs are a bit weak,
but he can do the same things as you
only in a different way.”
I think that pretty much gave me
an idea of myself
and how to live my life
and what to say to the world.
That was the beginning
of my wonderful social life.
Later, in kindergarten,
I was able to drive my power chair freely
and enjoy life.
By the age of 10,
I knew how to keep myself safe,
so I just needed a bit of assistance
for transfers and books.
Otherwise, I was independent
and so happy going everywhere
with my friends.
I have wonderful friends
from my school and my neighborhood.
I really enjoy spending time with them.
But can you imagine
how my childhood would look like
without my power chair?
I cannot.
I’m forever grateful to the family
that donated my power chair,
but my freedom
and independence
and ability should not depend on luck
or charity.
No one’s should be.
This assistive product
needs to be available
to everyone who needs it.
By the age of two,
most children are able
to walk on their own.
Those children who have
some sort of disability and can’t walk,
they should be given an AT,
an assistive technology,
in order to move.
If they have a proper wheelchair
from an early age,
they will have a great opportunity
to discover the world around them.
Freedom of movement,
no matter on legs or on wheels,
is a human right,
which means policymakers have to provide
what children with disabilities need
in order to move.
It’s about being able
to go to the park to play,
go to school,
go to work --
really, everything.
This chair is my legs.
This chair is my life.
The wheel was invented a long time ago.
And thanks to that invention,
I can move my stuff around.
So this time, literally, the wheel
doesn’t need to be reinvented.
We just need policies
to make sure that wheelchairs
are available to everyone in need.
But it’s not only just the wheelchair.
We also need physical infrastructure.
For example ramps,
elevators,
roads without obstacles,
accessible transportation,
school buses,
so our environment becomes
more accessible for all.
We live in a society
that’s not giving enough support
to fulfill the potential
of young people with disability,
like me.
We need to think about
how to change that at a global level.
If society removes the barriers
that prevent me
from doing everyday things,
I can become a very productive person
and give back to the society.
I have so much to contribute
of my intellect,
my brain.
I believe I can become
a lawyer or an architect,
whatever I want to.
Also, I’m an excellent football coach
and a strategist,
so I have that to contribute, too.
I have so many things I can do
to help my community,
my country
and the world.
We may think of that as a mutual benefit.
“How?” you may ask.
Let me tell you how I see it.
An able body doesn’t give you
a direct pass to a happy life.
A person able to walk
still needs help with other things --
things that I can do well.
So for example,
for me, helping a friend on a math test
is the same as him helping me
with my backpack.
I don’t see a difference.
He’s struggling, I’m struggling,
he’s good with his stronger hands,
I’m good with my strong knowledge;
we’re helping each other.
That’s what friends do,
and that’s what societies should do.
Once I was out with my friends
and an old man approached me
and started a very nice
and polite conversation.
By simply asking me, first,
“What is your condition?”
I felt deeply touched by the honesty
and simplicity of his question.
I was only 11
and felt so respected that he asked me
and felt very comfortable
to speak on my behalf
and answer him.
I explained to him why I can’t walk
and what I need in order to function.
Usually people only stare.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I know it's not
a standard picture of a child.
My wheelchair is very interesting.
I was even cuter when I was small.
But still,
it’s not comfortable when people stare.
It’s better not to stare, but to care.
If you see a wheelchair user,
rather than staring
and wondering about them,
look around
and see if there’s something
you can do to help.
If there aren’t ramps,
if doorways are too narrow,
maybe that’s something you could work
to get fixed in your building,
in your city
or in your country.
Each one of us can make a small change,
but governments
are supposed to make great changes.
I, and people like me, need help
from public policymakers
to be able to live
with freedom and independence.
I wish that more people
were like that old man,
asking me, and children
like me, what we need
and listening to our answers.
I told you at the beginning,
I love football.
Just in case I wasn’t clear,
I really love football, a lot.
And to me, the whole world
is like a giant football team.
But I took part in the campaign #EqualGame
not only because I love the game
but because I strongly believe
that everyone can play
all around the globe:
men, women,
abled, disabled,
young, old --
doesn’t matter.
All of them were able to find their way
to play the game that they love.
All they needed
was the barriers to be removed.
So I see this world as a playground
where people and government
are like a team,
and we need to make sure
that everyone is able to play.
Thank you.